françaises français
il y à 7 ans le peuple français me
confier la destinée de notre pays
cela a été un grand honneur pour moi de
le diriger dans un monde difficile
dangereux aux prises avec une crise
économique sociale et morale son
précédent depuis 50 ans
vous m'aviez donnée en garde les biens
les plus précieux de la collectivité
nationale
la paix la liberté et nos institutions
j'en étais le gardien et à l'heure où je
m'en vais ils vous sont restitués un
temps
aujourd'hui la volonté du plus grand
nombre a choisi un nouveau président
j'ai voulu que la transition se fasse
selon les règles de la continuité
républicaine
c'est pourquoi j'accueillerai moi même
monsieur françois mitterrand à l'elysée
ceci apportera la preuve du respect des
principes démocratiques
et du fonctionnement régulier de nos
institutions
après demain je quitterais l'elysée
je viens ce soir vous dire très
simplement
aurevoir
je quitte mes fonctions en ayant
conscience d'avoir apporté tous mes
soins et tous mes efforts à ce que je
juge est essentielle
je vous demande de vous souvenir de ceux
ci
pendant ces sept ans
j'avais un rêve
que la france devienne une nation forte
et paisible
fraternelle pour tous les siens et
traitant d'égal à égal avec les grands
dirigeants du monde
pendant ce temps la france a vécu en
paix
sans souffrir de secousses d'intérieur
grave ni politique ni sociales toutes
les élections ont eu lieu à leur date
normale
la france est restée le pays de toutes
les libertés
le déroulement de l'élection
présidentielle vient d'en apporter la
preuve elle fait même partie de ceux qui
n'est plus qu'un îlot de liberté dans un
océan de contraintes
chaque fois que nos forces ont tué à
intervenir à l'extérieur elles l'ont
fait avec succès cela restera mon
honneur de l'avoir décidé
si notre pays n'a pas connu toute la
prospérité que je voulais pour lui nous
avons maintenu pendant sept ans la
solidité du franc
limiter le déficit budgétaire
rétabli l'équilibré de la sécurité
sociale et sauver ainsi nos régimes
sociaux
je voulais aussi que les français soient
fiers de la france
je me suis donné beaucoup de peine pour
cela en vous représentants à l'étranger
chacun de vous en franchissant nos
frontières pouvait être être fier d'être
français
nous avons lancé de grands projets notre
programme d'indépendance énergétique
poursuivi sans défaillance
faisaient l'admiration du monde
j'ai développé l'entente
franco-allemande pour consolider
l'europe j'ai maintenu ouvert le
dialogue pour la paix
je veux maintenant remercier
chaleureusement
toutes celles et tous ceux d'entre vous
qui m'ont apporté leur suffrage au
nombre de 14 millions 600 mille
des suffrages populaires
courageux
modeste des suffrages qui reconnaissait
l'effort accompli et recherchait le bien
de la france
merci à vous tous qui de valenciennes à
thionville
d'alsace en bretagne des antilles à la
réunion
de la manche à la lozère de la
haute-savoie haut var et à la corse
m'ont aidé dans ma tâche et m'ont
apporté leur enthousiasme et leur
dévouement
la france continuera à avoir besoin de
vous chaque fois qu'il le faudra je
saurai pouvoir compter sur vous
en ce jour
qui marque pour beaucoup le terme de
grandes espérances
je sais que vous êtes nombreux à
partager mon émotion
sachez qu'un événement politique n'est
qu'un maillon dans la chaîne de notre
longue histoire
à ceux qui m'ont suivie jusqu'au bout je
demande d'oublier les blessures du
combat politique
pour ne retenir que l'attachement aux
grands idéaux qui restent les nôtres et
la volonté de resserrer l'union
chaque fois qu'elle est une condition du
succès
pour moi
je resterai attentif à tout ce qui
concerne l'intérêt de la france
tourné vers l'avenir et fort de
l'expérience acquise
je ferai en sorte de me tenir à la
disposition de mon pays pour défendre
les prix sips et les idées qui ont guidé
ma vie est inspiré mon action de 7 ans
avant de vous quitter
je vous souhaite bonne chance
à chacune et à chacun d'entre vous
oui bonne chance du fond du coeur sans
amertume vis-à-vis des 1 et avec une
chaude reconnaissance pour les autres
mais veut vont aussi à celui que les
français ont choisi pour être le premier
d'entre eux
est dans ces temps difficiles
où le mal rôde et frappe dans le monde
je souhaite que la providence veille sur
la france
pour son bonheur
pour son bien et pour sa grandeur
au revoir
raté
le
et
m